>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Fenella France: We're
delighted to have you all here
for the first day of
Cultural Heritage and Data:
The Role of Research
Infrastructures.
And it's my very great pleasure
to introduce John Van Oudenaren,
the director o Scholarly
and Educational Programs
and acting director of
the World Digital Library
to give the welcome to the library.
>> John van Oudenaren:
Thank you Fenella.
Thanks for inviting me here
and welcome to all of you.
It's great to be here
with some old colleagues,
belongs to any colleagues,
so my good friend Riccardo
Pozzo in particular.
Good morning and welcome
to the Library of Congress
and the two-day International
Symposium on Cultural Heritage
and Data: The Role of
Research Infrastructures.
Today's program will advance
our current understanding
of research infrastructures
focusing on current initiatives,
issues and challenges,
solutions, and the future landscape
of research infrastructures.
Our international colleagues
in IPERION CH and that stands
for Integrated Platform
for the European Research
Infrastructure on Cultural Heritage.
I assume you all know that.
But I read it out for my
benefit, if not for anyone else's.
The consortium is focused on
taking up the challenge outlined
in the Horizon 2020
Work Program 2014-2015
for European Research
Infrastructures,
which calls for the establishment
of a unique European research
infrastructure for restoration
and conservation of
cultural heritage.
Encompassed in this proposal
by the term heritage science,
where heritage science is a
crosscutting domain embracing a wide
range of research disciplines
according to various aspects
of tangible and intangible
cultural heritage conservation,
interpretation and management.
This challenge of course
encompasses the building of stronger
and more effective collaborations
between the EU and US partners.
Research infrastructures play
an increasingly important role
in the advancement of knowledge for
humanities and heritage science.
They are a key instrument in
bringing together a wide diversity
of stakeholders and offer unique
research services to users
from different countries, attracting
new researchers to humanities
and preservation science
and help to research--
and help to shape research
communities.
Research infrastructures help to
create a new research environment
in which all researchers
whether working in the context
of their home institutions
or in national
or multinational scientific
initiatives have shared access
to unique or distributed
research facilities,
including data instruments
computing and communications,
regardless of their type
and location in the world.
These initiatives are at the
center of the knowledge triangle
of research, education,
and innovation.
They produce knowledge
through research,
diffuse it through education
and apply it through innovation.
I trust you'll enjoy the
presentations outlining some
of the European Union and
US initiatives in this area.
And we look forward to stimulating
further collaborative efforts
to make best use of resources
to encourage the standardization
of procedures and to ensure access
internationally to advance research
for humanities and heritage science.
Once again, welcome and
thank you for joining us.
[ Applause ]
>> Fenella France: So I just wanted
to give a quick overview
of the next two days.
These-- Today's presentations
are being filmed
so all speakers have been
given a release form.
If you do not wish to have that put
up on the website,
then we will not do so.
But we're hoping that you
will all agree to do that.
And as part of that filming, we
will-- whenever there are questions,
I will actually ask-- one of us
will be here speaking the question
so that the film crew can
actually hear [inaudible].
So there have been a
number of organizers
who have helped make this
event come to fruition.
And so, we have Monique in
the front, Barbara, Odile,
Jong-on, Giulio and Stefano.
Thanks to everyone who have helped
with bringing this together.
So we are really looking at engaging
in these transatlantic dialogue
to understand more about how we can
be effective in the communications
and the collaborations that we bring
together in taking those forward
because we really are working now in
a global infrastructure and we need
to make sure that anything that we
kept during the data we're working
with is interoperable between
all our different initiatives.
These four main areas
that will be focused
on throughout the different
presentations, education
and training, innovative
instrumentation,
advancing diagnostics and digital
heritage, and you'll see both panels
and presentations on
those various areas.
I just want to note that we
had a similar meeting starting
to really engage and
thinking about working
with our international colleagues in
December 2014, and this was looking
at Fostering the Transatlantic
Dialogue.
And so, these presentations
were given here and we--
most people agree but we want to
get those up on our website as well
and by the link the
two events together.
So as John mentioned,
IPERION CH has been--
this is the focus behind
this meeting today.
And many of our colleagues
here who will be presenting
on the various initiatives,
we're delighted
to have those different projects
put forward because sometimes
in the states, we don't always get
to hear what's happening in Europe.
We also have presentation
of-- presentations, I'm sorry,
representatives from a number of
other initiatives that we've talked
about in the past and I will just
go through these for your interest.
ARIADNE which of course is
archeology database structure.
CENDARI, looking at it from
the humanities perspective.
DARIAH-EU, which is also the
Digital Research Infrastructure
for Arts and Humanities.
There's another one, we learned
last time to get very good
with all our different acronyms.
PARTHENOS, which is one of the newer
ones which was kickstarted in July
of 2015 and some of us were
privileged to be there,
really looking at where
the gaps are between some
of the various initiatives and
starting to pull all that together.
And E-RIHS, which I know
Luca will talk about,
the European Research
Infrastructure for Heritage Science,
which is a new focus to really
try and combine what's happening
across Europe with the
intent and the hope
that once we get passed looking
at some of the legal implications,
taking that into a global
perspective as well.
So a few things I just want to
focus on that you'll see coming
up throughout the various
presentations,
in terms of collaboration
and cooperation.
So we really want to
talk more effectively
and think more effectively
about what is collaboration
in an effective way.
And do specific types
of collaboration require
different approaches
and you may see this coming out
when we talk about education
versus digital, versus the
innovation and the diagnostics.
Also, the many changes
just happened last night
in both New Zealand and Italy.
How do we achieve sustained
collaboration,
a very constantly changing
economic and international climate
and keep things moving
forward particularly
because we often do not have
extensive funding for those.
And the sustainability of
international collaborations.
In terms of research and networking,
IPERION talks about
the joint research
for faster scientific advancement
and integrating the activities
for a more structured community.
And so, with those four areas,
we really are looking at teasing
out what collaborations
already exist
and how we can move those forward.
[Inaudible] speaks of this thinking
about how we can link
together the stakeholders
and sharing unique
research services.
Many of us are privileged to
have extensive laboratories,
but not all institutions
have those capabilities.
And so, how we can make more
effective model to engage
with other institutions and
share our resources is something
that we really need to
think about as we go forward
with the sustained approach.
And thinking of these aspects,
both as the physical resources,
the network of expertise
and colleagues,
which is a really critical component
that I think is really what
holds everything together
most effectively.
And then, one thing I think is
becoming even more critical is the
interoperability of the data and
making sure that people can access
that effectively that
isn't an open environment
and that we can share it, you
know, in effective manner.
So with sharing sustainability,
really thinking
about how do we make sure we got
these long-term collaborative
activities moving forward
across different cultures,
both economic and diverse natures.
This international sharing of
the resources and platforms
to actually initiate, engage
and allowed us to move forward.
I do just want to mention this
came out of our last meeting here
where it was very interesting
in fact where we started to look
at the differences between European
and United States approaches.
And one of the things we
realize in fact that, you know,
these are centralized
public funding model
versus a private model
here in the states.
And also we don't have the privilege
of having a Ministry of Culture
or similar in the United States.
And the need for us to really start
to think about as a collaboration
and a coalition of institutions here
in the states of how we can form
and engage grouping that allows us
to show a strength and united body
in terms of moving forward
to cultural heritage.
So, I just wanted to finish there.
Leave that to open up the meeting
and turn over to our first speaker
of the day, Dr. Riccardo Pozzo,
who's a director of Social Sciences
and Humanities, Cultural
Heritage Department
of the National Research
Council of Italy.
[ Applause ]
>> Riccardo Pozzo: And good morning.
It's a pleasure to be here.
I was already here and some
of you I already spoke.
So, I'm trying not to repeat
myself and just keep you update
in what has been happening.
Last time I spoke to you
it was about 10 months ago.
But first, on behalf of
the Italian co-chairs
of the joint Italy-US Committee
on Culture and Natural Heritage,
may I extend my deepest thank to
Fenella France and the Library
of Congress who organize
this and to her colleagues,
three of our co-chairs, American
co-chairs, namely Barbara Berrie,
Odile Madden and Jong-un Hahm.
Thank you very much.
It's a big pleasure to be here.
Now, you have all read the news
with it and it's not funny.
But anyway, I wanted to stay to
[inaudible] unflinching commitment.
The unflinching committee
of the Italian government
to sustaining what we are doing.
It's very important.
Fenella was saying,
there is no Minister
of Culture in the United States.
We have a Minister
of Culture in Italy.
And more for that,
we have a minister
of culture whose budget
covers 0.4 of the GDP, 0.4,
imagine 0.4 of the US
GDP what that would be.
In our case, it's 0.4.
It's actually less than that.
We got some cuts, it's about 0.3.
But still it's a lot of money.
And why do we have that?
Because we have this
enormous responsibility,
0.3 of the GDP goes
towards conservation,
protection, use of monuments.
That's defining our country.
Greece has similar
figures obviously.
But we are-- in the G8, we
are industrialized country.
We are very innovative
and we have that.
So that Fenalla France was writing
in her presentation science,
technology and Innovation.
Let me rephrase it.
Science, Technology,
Engineering and Mathematics STEM,
but we are actually going for
STEAM, Science, Technology,
Engineering, Arts and Mathematics.
That's a form we are
working on a little, STEAM.
Now as regards as the updates.
We had the ravishing
moment in March of 2016
when ESFRI accepted
the Italian CH project,
the Italian CH infrastructure.
As in this project, which
means about-- they change name.
We updated, upgraded the name.
Now the name is E-R-I-H-S, E-RIHS,
pronounce it the way you want.
New York or not New York.
And the European Research
Infrastructure Heritage Signs.
That's it.
It's the reality.
And we're talking about
sustainability.
So, in order to become
what is supposed to become,
E-RIHS has five years
counting now, 2016, 2021.
In 2021, E-RIHS would
be full fledged.
It will become a European
Research Infrastructure Consortium
and will start counting
years from there.
So, we have five years
working together very hard.
We will be established in 2021
and finally to see how ESFRI
and the European Union will consider
that infrastructure
has reached its peak
and there's nothing more innovative
to say, which means that sooner
or later, the European Union will
start reconsidering financing a
mature infrastructure.
And the infrastructure
will go on of its own legs.
That's the way we face
sustainability right now.
Five years preparation, a long
time as a mature infrastructure
and fans see what happens.
I'm quite aware of this
because I represent Italy
in all six European Research
Infrastructure for Social
and Cultural Innovation,
that's the way we're called,
with this research infrastructures
deal with matters of social sciences
and humanities or if you want social
innovation and culture innovation.
Six in numbers right now, five
landmarks and one project.
The project I mentioned
already, that's E-RIHS.
The landmarks are DARIAH, H, DARIAH,
Digital Research Infrastructure
of Arts and Humanities, CLARIN,
Common Language Resources,
that's for linguistics,
[inaudible] for social sciences,
the European Social Survey, CESSDA
which is public records and SHARE
for retirement, aging population.
Particularly SHARE is the one-- the
oldest one, the one that people say,
all right, all right, are you done?
You're mature.
You have nothing more to look.
In ways of making yourself
better, so SHARE is an example
of a research infrastructure, which
is not going to be financed anymore
in the next work programs.
And we have to find and-- but
still, this is a situation
in which we are not yet--
it's a long time to go.
But let me see again
a better scenarios.
2020 would be the end of Horizon
2020, 2021 would be the start
of FP9, Frame Program number nine.
So, we are currently looking at a
result of the midterm evaluation
of Horizon 2020, which
is more favorable
for research infrastructures.
There is no words of
them being reconsidered.
But still we have to make
sure about the work program
after work program we are in.
And-- So the best thing is
to look for business models.
And, you know, I congratulate
very much and look a bit certain
for his looking forward and
having considerate from the start
that E-RIHS, and let's
call it E-RIHS,
since now IPERION CH [inaudible].
So, I thought it's
a name as a project
that is currently sponsoring us.
But E-RIHS, E-RIHS
has a global impact.
So, it was the first
[inaudible] was the first--
he was the first to have
contacts with US scholars since he
in Washington, Los Angeles and
we've opened it up to China.
Chinese Economy, Culture,
and Heritage is a candidate
to becoming associate and
we have to look around.
So the global impact is there.
And we have to look at business
models that make it possible to work
on access units and see
that at the end of the year,
the fiscal distribution corresponds
to what we had planned it for.
Let me conclude.
We have a reference to the European
Union South Africa Joint Research
Agreement that was signed
in Cape Town two months ago
exactly, on October 4th.
And that is quite interesting
because the Minister for Science
and Technology and Innovation,
Madame Naledi Pandor,
who's really a woman to whom I
personally have a lot of respect.
She had engineered the agreement on
the basis of South Africans interest
in a very new research
infrastructure
of which perhaps you
might have heard,
which is called the Square Kilometre
Array was going to be built
in the desert of Kalahari.
And that's the gift of South Africa
for joining the European Union
on this great endeavor of
research infrastructures.
But when we signed the agreement,
we were there representing
all research infrastructures
currently active.
And it was clear that South Africa
too has an interest in the profits
in research gains that all
European infrastructures provide.
And particularly, the social
and cultural innovation
infrastructures,
we found sensible years.
More of that, we found the urgent
needs because if you take the issue
of migrants, which is
determining so much politics
and economics right now in Europe,
where in South Africa is it's just
as the same as we had,
only southward.
We have-- We welcome
migrants northbound.
We welcome migrants southbound.
So the idea is International
Corporation
of researches European Union.
We've [inaudible] can be a
great profit in a holistic way.
It's important that we come up with
our perspective and that we come
up we-- sorry, we Europeans.
We Europeans come up
with perspective,
which is distinctly European.
And what makes us currently
distinctly European is
interdisciplinarity,
multilingualism,
and the fact that whatever you do,
it's always a consortium
of plus 12 states.
This is a model that
we are proud of.
It has worked well.
It will work again, better.
And we are very thankful for
you, for your attentive years.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Fenella France:
Thank you Riccardo.
And now it gives me great pleasure
to introduce Mary Kavanagh,
who is the minister counselor
for Research and Innovation
in the delegation of the European
Union to the United States.
Thank you so much for being here.
>> Mary Kavanagh: Good
morning everybody.
And thank you Fenella.
Thank you to the organizers
for inviting me
to speak here this morning.
I have to say it's a
great honor to speak
at the Library of Congress
of course.
So thank you all very much.
Now, I know that you're all
specialists in cultural heritage.
I can put straight up.
I'm not specialist at all
but I'm a great appreciator
of cultural heritage.
And the reason that I'm invite--
was invited to speak this
morning was not to speak
about cultural heritage per se
because of course,
I'm not an expert.
But to speak to you about how
the European Union funds research
in cultural heritage and what
opportunities may exist there
between-- for transatlantic
cooperation.
So most of my presentation
will focus on Horizon 2020,
which is the European framework
program for research and innovation.
It covers the years
from 2014 to 2020,
which is why it's called
Horizon 2020.
And I will talk about
that in a moment.
But first, I just like to
mention a few other ways
in which the European Union
provides funding for support
of cultural heritage in Europe.
And firstly, it's important
to mention a program
called Creative Europe.
Now Creative Europe is a program
that is much broader than research
and it funds things in Europe such
as the European City of Culture.
It funds things like the Heritage
Days, where cities are encouraged
to open up buildings and
open up places to the public
that maybe they normally
don't have access to.
It also funds prizes for work on
cultural heritage throughout Europe.
So that's Creative Europe.
It has a budget for the cultural
part of the Creative Europe program
of about 422 million euros.
The second area where work on
cultural heritage is funded is
through our education
program and particularly
through the Erasmus Plus Programme.
And that is a program of--
that covers many areas.
But one particular area of interest
is it funds collaborative projects
for training between higher
education institutions.
These higher education
institutions can be in Europe
and they can also involve
partners from outside of Europe.
And that's really boosting
skills and education
to make people more
employable in whatever area.
But this also includes
cultural-- the cultural area.
And then a third area where
Europe provides a lot of funding
for our support and preservation
of European culture and heritage is
through what we call
the Cohesion Funds.
And the Cohesion Funds because you
know Europe has 28 member states.
And there is a great deal of-- that
a lot of difference in the incomes,
in the wealth of these
different areas around Europe.
Some of the areas of Europe that
perhaps are the least wealthy have--
in some cases, got some of the
most interesting cultural heritage.
So the Cohesion Funds are
funds which are provided
to the European member states.
And the member states
themselves indicate how they want
to spend them, so they say,
for example, we want to just--
we would like to use
Cohesion funds specifically
for preserving an archeological
site for example.
Or they may want to build, what
we call it, interpretive centers
to help maybe bring
more tourism to an area
and without damaging the actual
heritage itself provide a center
for our people to learn more
about the-- about that culture--
the cultural heritage
in that particular area.
So these are-- I just want to just
give you a kind of broad brush idea
of different ways in which the
European Union funds cultural
heritage in different ways.
But what I'll talk mainly
about is research policy,
and how research policy
funds cultural heritage--
supports cultural heritage research.
Now Professor Pozzo mentioned
already the way in which many
of the research infrastructures
which are funded
through Horizon 2020, which
is our research program.
And so I won't focus on that because
I know that throughout the next day
or so and next of couple of
days, you would hear a lot more
about the specific projects like
CLARIN and DALIAH and IPERION.
So I wan to say I'm not going
to try to squeeze them all
in to a short message now.
But those research infrastructures,
the European Union funds the stage
of [inaudible] of development of
these research infrastructures,
but as Sir Pozzo rightly said,
the European Union
research funds are not going
to fund these research
infrastructures forever
into the future, because
there are new ones coming
in line all the time.
So therefore, what the European
Union does want is the conceptions
and the development phase.
So, let me talk about some of
the other opportunities and let--
but let me first introduce a little
bit the program Horizon 2020.
I guess any of you who are
here from Europe but I know
that there was several European--
I heard several European
accents in the audience.
So you probably are already very
familiar with that but hopefully,
even you who are familiar
with Horizon 2020 will
learn something new today.
So let's see page down.
What is Horizon 2020?
Horizon 2020 is the European
Union's framework program
for funding research and innovation.
It is and always on upon--
it's upon European program.
So Horizon 2020 is one aspect,
one dimension of research
funding in Europe.
Because of course every member
state has its own research funding,
has its own department of--
departments of science
and technology.
But in addition to the individual
member state research programs,
we have Horizon 20202.
And Horizon 2020 has a
number of objectives.
The objectives are to develop
excellent science in Europe
to support-- and to
support European industry
and industrial competitiveness.
And of course, to strengthen the
European Union's global position
in research and innovation
in the technology.
And most importantly, Horizon
2020 is open to the world.
So researchers from anywhere
in the world can participate
in Horizon 2020 projects.
And I will describe how
in the coming slides.
Oh, and I should mention
that the financial envelope
of Horizon 2020 is about 77
billion euros over seven years,
which is present approximately
$80 billion.
So as I said, there are three
main priorities excellent science,
industrial leadership,
and societal challenges.
And what's interesting is under
for example, the excellent science
which I'll talk about, there
are a lot of opportunities
for individual researchers
in any area of science.
From physics to arts, to humanities,
to economic science,
all kinds of science.
Under the societal
challenges, which I will explain
in a little bit more detail also,
there are also many
opportunities specifically
for cultural heritage research
and innovation, and indeed also
under the industrial
leadership element,
which I will also talk
about briefly.
Yeah, I will talk about the
European Research Council
and the Marie Curie
actions a little bit later.
But let me start here with
the leadership in industrial
and enabling technologies.
Now, you might say to yourself, what
has that got to do with research
in the humanities, at least
I did, maybe you wouldn't
because you know much more than I do
about research on cultural heritage.
But this aspect of
Horizon 2020 leadership
and industrial technologies
covers technologies such as ICT,
nanotechnologies, materials,
biotechnology,
manufacturing, and space.
And as an example there, there's--
Horizon 2020 by the way would
publish calls for proposals.
So therefore, research
proposals have to come
in following these
calls from proposals.
But for example in the
materials research section,
in the 2017 work program, there
is a section on new materials
for preserving and
protecting cultural heritage.
So therefore, what's important
to realize is particularly
with Horizon 2020, not if
you're looking for opportunities
in Horizon 2020, not to
look only for, you know,
for a section that's
called cultural heritage.
But it's-- very often it's
mainstreamed through different parts
of the Horizon 2020 program.
That's one example.
Likewise in ICT under the
European digital agenda,
there are opportunities far-- as
was mentioned actually earlier
by Fenella of working on how to
make for example data interoperable,
how to make data accessible
internationally.
And this can be-- equally
it can be the--
in the context of cultural heritage
just as it could be in the context
of any other type of research.
So if we take a look at some the
societal challenges that are funded
by Horizon 2020 and just
as a small reminder,
you remember that there
were these three circles.
So you have societal challenges,
you have industrial leadership,
and you have research excellence.
We just talked about the
leadership opportunities.
Now we look at the
societal challenges.
Most of the cultural
heritage research is funded
under what we call societal
challenge six, which is inclusive
and reflective societies.
Now inclusive and reflective
societies
in Horizon 2020 is a followup of
similar research program that we had
because prior to Horizon
2020, which starts in 2013--
in 2014, we also had
another research program.
It was called Framework Programme 7.
And under Framework Programme
7, I just have to [inaudible]
so that I can indicate
the correct amount.
Under Framework Programme 7, we also
funded cultural heritage research
to the tune of 180 million euros.
So therefore, that was under
the previous framework program.
So this Framework Programme Horizon
2020, we can also expect although
of course it's only started.
It's only two years done, so we
have quite a ways to go to 2020.
But we can expect that
funding for research
on cultural heritage
will be at least
of the same dimension depending on
the projects that come in of course.
But some of the types of
projects, of research project
that are included for
example under inclusive
and reflective societies
are for example projects
such as religious diversity in
Europe or how young people engage
with culture-- oops, sorry.
Another interesting
one which is actually
in the 2017 work program
is cultural heritage
of European coastal
and maritime zones.
So therefore, it's really
quite a broad panoply
of topics that are-- that come up.
So I say, the 2017 work
program has a number
of specific culture heritage
research opportunities.
But it's not only inclusive
on reflective societies,
the six cultural-- the
six societal challenge,
where opportunities exist.
Opportunities also exist as I said
because it's mainstreamed
to a certain extent.
In other areas, for example under
keen and efficient energy, there--
in 2017 call, there is a
call for research on how
to renovate historic buildings
to upgrade them energetically
for example.
Under climate action resource
efficiency and raw materials,
there is a call for
proposals, how natural--
how to build resilience in cultural
heritage against natural disasters?
So therefore again, I'm-- I
repeat myself but when looking
at Horizon 2020 don't
go only at the--
under the obvious heading
which would be inclusive
and reflective societies where
there is a lot of research
and opportunities for cultural
heritage research but also
under other areas because
under other areas also you will
find opportunities.
And then I want to-- sorry,
maybe just before I come
on that, I should indicate.
These projects under
these societal challenges,
they're always collaborative
research project.
So they almost always must have
at least three European partners
from three different
European countries.
They can however include partners
from any other part
of the world also.
Generally if these partners
come from developing countries,
such as Africa and we do actually
quite a lot of work with Africa
or some of the less
developed countries,
for example in Latin America.
If the projects include
partners from those countries,
the European Union will fund fully
the participation of those partners
if the project is selected.
For countries such
as the United States,
which is an industrialized country,
the European Union generally
does not fund the participation
of the American partner.
The American partner is expected to
bring their own funds to the table.
But what's the advantage
for the American partner?
Well, the advantage of course for
the American partner is the access
to all of the work that is being
done by the other partners,
and it's the access to that
network, access to the new results
that are being produced
but also being part
of the new results that
are being produced.
So it's really an opportunity
for international cooperation
at a very high level.
So therefore that's why we say
Horizon 2020 is open to the world
and we really encourage and
like to have American partners.
So any Europeans in the
audience who are thinking
of preparing Horizon 2020 projects
to submit, please do remember
that American partners are extremely
welcome and any Americans who are
in the audience who have good ideas
for research projects and would
like to internationalize them,
then please don't hesitate to speak
with some European partners
and look at the opportunities
that Horizon 2020 might
be able to provide to you.
Another aspect I would like to
mention regarding Horizon 2020
that you may or may not be familiar
with are the European
Research Council grants.
And the European Research
Council grants are relatively new
in European research funding terms.
Actually 2017 will be
the 10th anniversary
of the European Research Council.
And since the European
Research Council was set up,
it has been funding individual
investigators at a very,
very high level with very
prestigious, very generous grants.
Any researcher from anywhere
in the world can apply
for European Research Council grant.
One of the stipulations however
is that that person must spend
at least 50% of their
time in Europe.
Because the idea of the European
Research Council grants is
that people will set
up a lab in Europe.
Now, I'll be very brief on this
because I could talk about it
for half a day because it's one
of my favorite topics,
but I'll be very brief.
There are three main types of grant.
There are grant for-- they're
called Starting Grants.
Most of the money goes
to starting grants.
And these are for individuals
who are ready to set
up their own research
lab for the first time.
The researcher who applies must
nevertheless be able to demonstrate
that they have really
the capacity and the--
really show the potential
to make a difference
in their chosen area of research.
And what's very important is that
the area of research can be any area
of research including of course
humanities, cultural heritage
and the arts, as well as
physics or brain science.
It can be anything.
Then we have a-- there's
a second type of grant
which is called the
Consolidator Grant.
The consolidator grants
are for people who are
at a more advanced stage in their
research career and they have a--
Well, they want to consolidate.
They probably already
have a small lab perhaps.
They have already a number
of serious publications.
And they have between 7 and
12 years after their PhD.
And then finally, we
have the Advanced Grants,
which are far much more senior
researchers who want to come
and spend some time in-- who want
to develop a research program
in Europe, set up a lab
or a research group.
It doesn't have to be a lab, of
course it can be a research group.
And there also, you can see
that it's very generous.
And you can see that they're very
generous grants for individuals.
And the idea is that they
set up a research group.
Now, I said they have to spend at
least 50% of their time in Europe,
generally the starting grants will
spend most of their time in Europe.
If you're going to set up your
own lab for the first time,
you're not only going
their part time.
But it's very interesting for a
consolidator or in advanced grant
to know that you don't have to
spend all of your time in Europe.
So therefore, if you have a
position here at a university
and that university allows you
to, you can go and, you know,
open a new lab or set up
a new group in Europe.
And in particular, the
advanced grants you only need
to just spend 30% of
your time in Europe.
What's also interesting
I would like to say
about this European Research
Council grants is that of course,
once you set up your research
group or once the person
who was selected sets up their
research group, they can have--
they can staff their
group with researchers
from anywhere in the world.
So this is also an
interesting opportunity.
They have to publish
all of those posts.
Well, they publish
most of those posts
and those posts are all advertised.
So a person who is interested
in coming to Europe to work
in cultural heritage could
for example apply for a grant,
which is very prestigious
if you are selected.
But there's also the option to
look at posts that are published
in the research groups of people
who have already gotten a grant.
So therefore all you
have to do is apply
for a job rather than
apply for a grant.
So this is also an option.
And I would specifically
like to mention that all
of the European Research Council
grantees also have the possibility
to host a temporary, on a temporary
basis from maybe three months
to nine moths, an NSF-founded
career grantee.
Because there's a special
implementing arrangement
between the National
Science Foundation
and the European Research
Council, which allows--
so the NSF continues to support
the US researcher and the--
and pay their travel to Europe.
And the European Research
Council grantee--
investigator supports them
while they're in Europe.
So you know, give some daily
allowance, so to speak.
So I just wanted to talk
there about the opportunities
that the European Research
Council offers.
There's also another
opportunity for individuals,
which is the Marie
Curie Fellowships.
The Marie Curie Fellowships we tend
to say are more on-- more upstream.
So therefore, they tend to be people
who are just going to do a postdoc.
If you are applying for a Marie
Curie Fellowship, you wouldn't be
at the same stage as if you
were applying for an ERC grant.
But a Marie Curie Fellowship,
again, very well paid.
It's a job.
It's not just a grant.
And these fellowships are
interesting and I don't have a lot
of time, so I won't spend
a lot of time on it.
But the Marie Curie Fellowships
are very interesting firstly
because anybody in the
United States can apply
for a Marie Curie Fellowship
to go and work in Europe.
So, if for example, you hear
in the next couple of days
about some wonderful projects
that would be able to host you
as an American, you can apply for
the Marie Curie Fellowship to come
to Europe for two years, and
you would get paid for that.
Also you get traveling allowance,
you get language training.
So it's very, very--
they're very nice.
It's a very nice scheme.
Also very interestingly, it
works in the opposite direction.
So if there's a European who
is interested to come to work
in the United States in perhaps
one of your groups for a while,
they have the opportunity to apply
for a Marie Curie Fellowship also
to go to the United States.
Well, they can go anywhere in
the world, but since I'm here
in America, I'm going to
talk about the opportunity
to come to the United States.
So therefore this is also
something that's interesting for you
to be aware of, if for example you
have a European who is saying, "God,
I really like to come
but I don't know how I"--
you don't maybe have
the funding for them.
It's really interesting
because basically
for the American side,
it's a free postdoc.
For the European side,
what's very interesting is
that the European postdoc who
gets the opportunity to come
to America must return to
Europe for at least one year.
So therefore, Europe
benefits also from what
that person learns
in the United States.
So it's really a win-win situation.
Well, I think I touched
on this a little bit.
Why would American researchers
be interested to participate
in Horizon 2020 project,
particularly in the
collaborative research projects?
Obviously, there's the access to
expertise, equipment and facilities,
economies of scale and
scope when you're dealing
with very large projects,
increased research quality,
greater impact efficiency and speed,
developing networks and alliances
which of course we all know in
science is very, very important.
Career development opportunities
such as those of the ERC
and Marie Curie, which
I just mentioned to you.
And eventually business and
commercialization opportunities
because if you work together and
develop a new means, for example,
of preserving some particular
type of cultural heritage,
well maybe it's something
that can be sold to museums
around the world, for example.
So I think I've gone through
the participation possibilities
as ERC grantees, as
Marie Curie Fellowships,
collaborative research projects.
And I also mentioned that
for US partners generally,
funding is not available,
but nevertheless there
are a lot of advantages.
Oops, I also briefly touched
on the rules for participation.
There have to be at least
three European parties
in a collaborative research project.
In the collaborative
research project.
Of course, for the Marie Curie
Fellowships, all you need in order
to apply for Marie Curie
Fellowship is you need
to have a really good project
idea and a host institution,
whether you're going to Europe
or going to the United States.
And of course, these are
all very competitive.
But nevertheless, as
we say in Ireland,
if you're not in, you can't in.
So therefore you have to, you know,
put your research projects together.
And likewise with the European
Research Council, again,
those grants are aimed at
individuals, individuals out of--
who are really the-- on the
cutting edge of the research
in their area, whatever it is.
And those research project also what
you need is a brilliant research
idea evidence that you're
able to carry it out
and a host institution
that's willing to host you.
I think I can honestly say that
for anybody interested in coming
in to Europe for-- within ERC
grant or a Marie Curie Fellowship,
I think most European institutes
would be very happy to host,
obviously if it's within
their research program.
But also because these
grants are prestigious
for the European hosting
institution also.
And of course they get overheads,
so that's also interesting.
So, of course, the
evaluation criteria are
for collaborative research projects,
excellence, impact and the quality
and efficiency of the action.
For the European Research Council
grants, there's only one criterion
and that's research excellence.
But for the collaborative
research grants,
there were three standard
award criteria.
So, I'll finish on this, which is
an advert for the participant portal
where you be able to find a
lot more detail on everything
that I briefly touched
on this morning.
The topics that are open for
research proposals at the moment,
documents explaining
how to apply the rules
for participation an
online manual and how
to submit a proposal electronically.
There's one other thing that I
would like to mention, however,
which is that all of these
project proposals that we get
at the European level
and we get a lot.
You can imagine thousands
every year.
It's like any funding agency here.
They all have to be evaluated.
And the European Union is always
very interested in having evaluators
from across the world to insure
an international standards
to the research that we're
funding but also to, you know,
have an outsider's view on the type
of research that we're funding.
So, also on the participant's
portal, you will find a link
to how to become an evaluator.
And we always encourage
people who might be interested
to consider becoming an evaluator.
The evaluators for Horizon
2020 projects are paid
for the collaborative
research projects,
so therefore there's a-- it's paid.
The first stage of the
evaluation is remote,
so therefore you would simply
receive the projects electronically
at home to evaluate.
On the second part is a
panel discussion in Brussels
to rank the successful proposals.
So, therefore, I just
to say to encourage you
to consider becoming
an evaluator also.
It's also a very good way to learn
what makes a successful project.
So, with all of that, I would
like to thank you very much
for your attention and encourage
you to consider Horizon 2020
when you're looking at your
next research projects.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Giulio Busulini: So I will
replace Fenella just very briefly.
I'm Giulio Busulini, one of the
science attach at Embassy of Italy.
So this session is
open to questions.
And if there are anyone is
willing to raise their hands,
we can maybe pick up
a question from him.
We're using this microphone.
In the meantime, I have
a question for Mary.
I mean, I really appreciate
your spectrum overview
about the Horizon 2020.
Can you maybe explain more details
in relation to the collaboration
between Italy-- sorry,
between US and Europe?
What have been signed
between [inaudible] State
and the European Commission in the
last few months, because I think
that is something that
really opened the opportunity
to leverage both funding on
both sides of the Atlantic.
So if you can just say a few
words, we really appreciate it.
Thank you.
>> Mary Kavanagh: OK.
Thank you, thank you
for raising that.
An American entity or an American
institution can participate
in Horizon 2020 in a collaborative
project in a number of ways.
The most common way is to
become a full participant,
that is to be in the project
proposal from the very beginning,
have the proposal selected and
to sign the grant agreement,
even if you're not getting funding.
So, it always sounds funny that
you've signed the grant agreement
without getting any funding.
But the grant agreement
is, I suppose, only a term
but it's the contract that we have
that the research we're
funding will be carried out.
So this is the most basic way and
the most common way of participating
in Horizon 2020 project for
an American institution.
And there's also a
possibility to participate
as what we call a third party.
Sometimes an institution-- an
American institution for example,
will carry out a particular
discreet piece of work for one
of the European partners.
And this can be funded or unfunded.
So in a way, it's a little
bit like a subcontract
that an American partner will
get but strongly linked to one
of the European partners.
So that European-- so then the
American partner does not have
to sign the grant agreement
because it's the European partner
who signs the grant agreement
and so as well, we're outsourcing
that piece of work to
an American partner
but we are responsible
that the work is done.
Now, those were the two options
up until recently because, well,
those were the two
options that existed.
But there was a problem
because some US institutions,
particularly federal research
institutions like NOAA for example,
but also some universities,
had a problem.
They had a problem with signing
the grant agreement and they said,
listen, we really want to
collaborate with Europe.
We see all of the advantages, but
we cannot sign the grant agreement
because the grant agreement is--
because we're not receiving
any funding.
The grant agreement is too heavy
a document for us to sign as to.
It commits us to too
many legal commitments.
This is only in some cases.
Many university sign without
any problem because they don't--
they just don't have that problem.
So therefore, in order
to relieve that problem,
the United States Department
of State
and the European Commission
worked on finding a solution.
And the work to find the
solution took a long time.
The solution itself is
supremely simple and elegant,
and it simply means that
the European project
and the American partner
can simply--
once the European has
the European funding
and once the American
has the American funding,
they can collaborate together
without anybody having
to sign anybody else's
grant agreement.
So therefore, what it basically
means is that the European project,
Horizon 2020, even if it knows
from the beginning that it's going
to have-- that is going to work
together with an American partner,
doesn't even have to
mention the American entity
in the research proposal.
The American partner likewise,
you know, request its own funding
from its own national
funding mechanism.
And only at the end,
they come together
and they decide themselves the
extent of their collaboration
and they decide amongst themselves
the extent of the sharing
of resources, the sharing
of knowledge.
And this was considered to be the
easiest because those who want
to collaborate very deeply
can collaborate very deeply.
It's entirely up to
the funded projects.
And those who want only a
lighter form of cooperation maybe
within occasional workshop together
or something can do it that way.
But it's entirely up to them.
So therefore, it leaves a lot of
liberty to the research projects.
And it relieves a US partner of
having to sign a grant agreement
if their university
regulations are--
federal regulations don't allow it.
So, thank you.
That's basically in a nutshell
what the new implementing
arrangement does.
>> Giulio Busulini: In my opinion,
and just to leave the floor
also, Fenella just came back.
To strategize a little bit better
from the funding perspective
so that we are able define together
new fund scheme that allowed
to have not any barriers from
the consortium agreement,
on the grant agreement
that kind of impediment
and facilitate the research
dialogue in a more proactive way.
So, that is the thing that the
goal of the discussion today.
We try to identify how we can
leverage our European scheme
in a more proactive
way with the US, one,
and see how we can use
also the opportunity
of the research infrastructure
commitment that we have on Europe
in a more interest and
proactive in the next future.
So I leave the floor to
Fenella who just came back.
>> Fenella France: Can
you please join with me
in thanking our speakers.
[ Applause ]
So we're going to move forward now
and moving now to sort of looking
at the landscape of heritage
science in the US and Europe.
And I think it's very interesting
for us, particularly here in the US
because there is so many
wonderful initiatives.
And as you've heard from Mary
and Riccardo, just the difference
in the way projects are funded
and the collaboration is
a very different focus.
So, I'd like to introduce
Monique Bossi,
who is the Italian
National Contact Point
for research infrastructures
for APRE.
And so I'm going to ask
you to come forward.
And we also have Luca Pezzati on
my left, who you've already heard,
who is the coordinator of IPERION
CH, the National Research Council
of Italy and Odile Madden from
Research Scientist and head
of modern materials research
at the Smithsonian Institution
Conservation Institute.
And between them, they will be
talking about differences and foci
on particular projects
and initiatives
in both the US and America.
>> Monique Bossi: OK.
Thank you.
Thank you Fenella.
OK. So I think we are all
very pleased to be here today.
For us, it's a big
privilege and we are happy
to share with you this session.
We are now moving from a
general let's say introduction
that any way we deem necessary
to set the frame a little bit
of the aim of the discussion today.
And as I said, we are moving
towards a more concrete part
of the discussion.
And in particular, we will now
try to landscape what's going
on in Europe and in the
US with specific respect
of research infrastructures in
the science heritage domain--
in the heritage science
domain, sorry.
So just one word about what we
mean by research infrastructures.
Research infrastructures
under the frame
of the discussion today is continued
to be any type of facility,
any type of support, any
type of piece of equipment
that can help any type of
researchers for whatever field
to perform their activity.
They can be single sided,
they can be distributed,
they can be physical, virtual,
whatever type of support as far
as it is accessible from researchers
from outside the institution, so--
that owns the facility of course.
So as you can see, when
it's a broad spectrum
of possibilities we are
varying some examples today.
We will have an insight
of which type
of infrastructures are
available now in Europe.
And as we said, because the
program is open to the world,
all these facilities are open to
US researchers that might need
to access them to perform
their research
and continue their activity.
So the session actually structure
on four different interventions.
So we were having first Luca Pezzati
from the National Council
of Research.
He will present what has been done
so far and the path that we have--
that we went through so
far in the specific field
of research infrastructure
for the cultural heritage.
And also will picture a
little bit where we're going.
Some have been already
said by Professor Pozzo.
But we would have now
some more detailed
and practical information
on the way forward.
And then Odile will
picture as well this--
I mean, will try to picture the same
frame for what's going on in the US.
That's the basic aim of the agenda,
the basic concept of the agenda,
to have always a comparison between
the European and the US landscape
or opportunities so that at the
end of these two days symposium,
we can really have clear picture and
ideas of which are the possibilities
and opportunities for both
part of the ocean to cooperate
and to go farther in the scientific
and innovational-related activities.
After, we would have a short
break and after that, we come back
and we have these two
second presentations
and in particular Mr. Jan
van't Hof from the Netherlands
from the Minister of Health
in Netherlands will continue
presenting another initiative,
which is the joint program
in initiative funded
by European Commission.
And then there is a change in
their agenda as you can see,
Elizabeth Tran cannot
be here with us today.
But Ms. Jong-on Hahm, we
thank her, accepted to replace
and she will give a little
bit of insight of what's going
on for the transatlantic platform
for social science and humanities.
Well, thank you Jong-on
for your ability.
I think we can start as we are
a little bit behind schedule.
So thank you Luca for
your presentation.
>> Luca Pezzati: Thank you Monique.
And which is the microphone?
This one? And thank you Riccardo
for having a quick landscaping
of the social and cultural
innovation domain
in the ESFRI roadmap in Europe.
So it seems that I am
left with the details.
Details, details.
We had these very long
initiative stepping back
from Framework Program 5.
So we are speaking of 15
years ago, more than 15.
When we started the collaboration to
European level in cultural heritage,
this is the stream of projects
that have been financed
by the European Commission,
trying to integrate
in European research infrastructure
for cultural heritage.
The last one in this stream of
project is the project IPERION CH,
which organized jointly with the
American institution involved
that they have today here.
But we didn't stop with
the IPERION CH project.
So I need to show you
what happened after it.
IPERION CH project was an
improvement, the third improvement
to this community and
included an American partner.
We have the pleasure of having here
is the [inaudible] Conservation
Institute in the partnership
that's covering 13 states,
12 states in Europe
and one here at the US.
The project is an integrating
activity
that is the technical
name in Europe.
The grant is 8 million and we
are now approaching the midterm.
The midterm meeting will
be [inaudible] in May.
So we still have two and a
half years of this initiative.
And the initiative is quite
big because we have a lot
of research groups involved now
in this research infrastructure.
Monique is playing the-- well,
this, the concept more or less
of research infrastructure
in Europe.
I will try to explain what
this project is doing actually.
Because the main activities of
the project providing services
as a research infrastructure.
And I will show you the services.
Then the idea underneath the
proposal of IPERION CH was to try
to structure something
more long term, let's say,
because as you may know, projects
are short term by nature and also
in this case, we have
initiatives that can last three
to five years, no more than that.
So the idea was to try to start
to kick off a permanent
research infrastructure dealing
with cultural heritage in Europe,
thus trying to help the
scientific community using it.
And this started considering
conservation or restoration,
so strictly speaking cultural
heritage issues in Europe.
But very soon we realize
that the horizon
of this should have
been more inclusive.
And so we finally decided to apply
for a research infrastructure
covering the needs
of the wider community of
heritage science, whatever it is.
By the way, the main activities
of an integrating project,
integrating activity
are of three natures.
The first is providing services and
we call that transnational access.
So the infrastructure is
providing services to research.
The second activity is
upgrading these services
by doing joint research altogether.
The third, but not the least
important activity is insuring a
continuous of networking between
the European facilities providing
the services.
This is very important
because under the networking,
you do a lot of things.
You do the policies
of the infrastructure.
You do the training.
You do a lot.
You do-- you organize event,
international events,
European events.
So the budget is limited
but the activity
of networking is very important
because it covers the
assistance that the future needs.
About the services, the IPERION CH
infrastructure is providing three
kind of services to research.
The first is having
mobile instruments going
where the artworks are and
having analytics of diagnostics
of several impossible kinds
of physical, chemical.
And this is called mobile
laboratory, so MOLAB.
Then we provide services linked to
access to non-mobile laboratories.
In the case of IPERION CH,
we only covers access
to landscape facilities.
It's a [inaudible] room and two
accelerator in the mutual source.
It is specialized in cultural
heritage applications.
Then we provide access to archives.
I use to call them
nondigital archives.
But actually archives are archives
and they are nondigital
by definition.
We are immersed in this digital
world, so we need to specify
that these archives are nondigital.
Archives where scientific documents
are including actually pieces
of artworks, if you consider
cross-sections for instance
or you can have samples
of pigments, samples of--
so real physical object, as well
as non-digitized documentation.
So currently, we are also
providing travel and accommodation
for researchers who apply
for going to archives.
In IPERION, we realized very
keen international interest
in the initiative and that
is what produced our proposal
as European infrastructure
with global scope.
One of the first interests that
we collected, very important,
is the interest of the
intergovernmental organization,
ICCROM, with who we are
cooperating strictly in these years.
And then here is the landscape,
is what is currently going
on in infrastructure at ESFRI level
in the social and cultural
innovation.
It explains graphically
what Riccardo was saying.
We have a cluster of
project PARTHENOS.
We have two ERIC already defined,
two consortia, DARIAH and CLARIN.
We have one single project.
It's the only one currently in the
roadmap and there it will remain
until the mid of 2018 with the
next upgrade of the roadmap itself.
And I have to point out that the
E-RIHS project was the cooperation
resulting from the cooperation
collaboration of the IPERION CH
who got the initiative of
proposing the E-RIHS but also
with the digital archeology
infrastructure, ARIADNE,
who agreed to run together with us
and other national
communities in Europe.
And so it happened that in
March 2016, so we are speaking
of nine months ago,
the E-RIHS was included
in the new strategic roadmap of
research infrastructures in Europe.
And this is the actual
roadmap already discussed.
This is very important because
it has became not anymore an
integrating activity but
actually a strategic project
of the European Union.
I don't want to discuss because
we don't have enough time,
what is heritage science.
Heritage science concept
is open to discussion.
Very briefly and my mind
is making signs together.
So not anymore science
for conservation,
not anymore users our museums.
No, we are all there
together to do science
for the heritage preservation.
That is my concept in general
lines, where general lines.
And so we define this
infrastructure with the specific aim
to support the heritage
science community.
And I must say that probably the
infrastructure will be first.
And then the heritage
science community,
because we are still discussing
in several countries about how
to define the real borders, the real
extension of what we have in mind.
And we need to know that because
we need to organize the services
of the big infrastructure covering
the needs of heritage science.
So some exercise of analysis
and strategic planning
and the discussion is open.
What is important this is the most
interdisciplinary infrastructure
in Europe.
And we have in the
disciplinary in the provision
of services and in the user groups.
What we will need to do
is two difficult things,
but we need to do them both.
Otherwise, the infrastructure
will not work.
We will meet to define
a common approach
to diagnostic methodologies,
analytics.
Otherwise, we will not
have consistent data.
And so we will not help research.
We will continue supporting
the fragmentation
of research in cultural heritage.
So we first need to
establish a common approach.
So first in the creation of
practices, best practices in methods
but also in the use of this data.
So we need to define a common data
infrastructure for heritage science.
I don't know what of these two
things to do is the most difficult.
But I only know that
we need to do both,
because my motto is not digital
common data, no infrastructure
at all due to the complexity
of the scientific landscape
of institutions involve,
multidisciplinary and all things.
We actually will need
common platform.
We will need to the
common data infrastructure.
Otherwise our languages--
we like [inaudible].
Everybody will speak their own
languages and we will never to get
to something integrated when
it comes to heritage science.
So what happened after IPERION?
What happened after IPERION
is that we propose E-RIHS
and E-RIHS has been supported
initially by 12 European countries
up to the time of submitting the
E-RIHS proposals, so June last year.
The countries were 16 plus two
ERICs involved, DARIAH ERIC
and CLARIN ERIC involved.
And then now we have more
interest at political level for--
from three more countries
that entered this--
the E-RIHS initiative, that
Austria, Romania and Sweden.
We have also contacts at
scientific level including here
with several countries ruled the
strongest in non-European network
that we have in this moment is the
Brazilian one, is already structured
in private association
of laboratories supporting
E-RIHS in Brazil.
What is going to happen?
This is just a map, a
physical map of this.
The structure that
we have in mind is--
have a strong central hub and
strong national hubs helping
to coordinate the services
of the infrastructure
everywhere it will be established.
We added one service platform to
the three already served by IPERION.
And this service platform will be
DIGILAB and we think that we need
to have a common platform either
for scientific data sets and tools
for research as one of the
future services of the E-RIHS.
So for these two years, we will
continue running the services
of the IPERION platforms.
And we will try to
establish the fourth one
that for the moment
is only planning.
So these are more or less
examples of just photographs.
Before I finish and I have seven
minutes, but I can use less.
I have to say about the
global dimension of E-RIHS
because it's very important.
And I think it's important
here, the US,
for the discussion
that we will have.
I was in Venice six days ago
and I met with the ESFRI chair
that now is an Italian guy.
So that's not news.
Also the old chair of ESFRI was an
Italian guy, it was Carlo Rizzuto.
Then we have an English guy for
a couple of years, Womersley.
And now again, we have Giorgio
Rossi from the University of Milan,
which is the ESFRI chair.
And I had a discussion with
Giorgio about what will happen
at global level with E-RIHS.
There are very nice news.
The first news is that in
March there will be the G7
of science in Italy.
And in May, there will be the GSO,
Group of Senior Official meeting
including the G7 and plus 5.
So the full group of
senior officials dealing
with global school
research infrastructures.
And Giorgio will be the
next president of the GSO.
So it will be both enforced
as ESFRI chair from mid-2017
and president of the GSO.
E-RIHS is one of the infrastructure
proposed shortlisted for the list
of global impact infrastructure
in the GSO list.
And what are the GSO's
officials-- what are doing now.
They are collecting as presumed of
interest from the countries involved
within the GSO that are simply 13.
But the US is there.
They are collecting expression of
interest to come to the final list
of global research
infrastructure to be supported.
It kind of a planetary
ESFRI roadmap.
It's a political matter.
No money implied at least
for the first stage.
So what is my message that
could be very interesting
to close these two days of
discussion with a lector
from the American institution
interested in E-RIHS
to your American delegates
in the GSO.
They are two.
Now, I have the names
but I don't know
if the two will be the same much for
obvious reason that you can guess.
Anyway, you will know who these
two will be before the meeting
in Italy will happen
because it will be very nice
to have the American expression of
interest for E-RIHS to be included
in the list of global
infrastructure.
So I think that after
two days of discussion,
if we can get to a short
letter of that kind,
it could be very nice closing for
this initiative that we have here.
Of course, the same is I see a
lot of European colleagues here.
The same holds also for France,
for all the European countries
which have representatives
in the G7.
Or for the let's say not at all--
not yet, non-European
countries in the G7.
I see Joseph, he's there.
So, we will-- by the way G7,
you know, it covers still UK.
The position of UK would
be very, very important.
So, if you simply-- even me, I
can provide you with the names
of the GSO contacts in your country.
It will be very, very
important if next year,
E-RIHS collect several
expression of interest from the--
this very small group of people
so that we can continue the road
to globalization in a certain sense.
ICCROM is very interested
in supporting us,
and the idea that we have is while
we establish E-RIHS in Europe
in these five years that
Riccardo cited this morning.
At the same time, we work to
establish RIHS at global level.
So at global level in
heritage science infrastructure
in which we will need help
because establishing a global,
legal figure is not very easy
in international research
infrastructure.
So we need to decide
a lot of things.
We need to see if there is
a real commitment and from
which countries this could be
issued towards this achievement
that of course will greatly help
the two points in the mission
that I was presenting before.
Because if we are capable of
organizing of reaching harmonization
in methodologies, its
European level, it's one thing.
If we can see to have a
harmonization of diagnostics
and on the use of digital
at the global level,
these will be much,
much more interesting.
So with this, I save the one
minute probably and I can leave you
and thank you for your attention.
[ Applause ]
>> Monique Rossi: So now we continue
with our landscaping exercise.
And we have the pleasure to
have here Mr. Jan van't Hof,
from the Dutch Minister of Culture.
And he is presenting now another
initiative that has been funded
by the European Commission, which
is called The Joint Programming
Initiative for Cultural Heritage.
So, and here we would have the
possibility to see another type
of approach from the
European Commission side,
which is not funding activities,
but funding, funding activities.
So it's a different scope
but it's very well placed
in the frame of our
discussion today.
So. Mr. Jan van't Hof, please.
>> Jan van't Hof: Thank
you very much.
So thank you very much
for the introduction.
Am I to be heard by
everybody or should I-- yes?
So I don't have to adjust it.
So in-- like it was said, my
name is Jan van't Hof and I'm
from the Dutch Cultural
Heritage Agency
and a part of the Ministry Culture.
And like a former speaker
said, while there are introvert
and extrovert people around and
well [inaudible] whether you find me
after this presentation
introvert or an extrovert person
and I will be glad to hear
your remarks during the break.
So, since I know some of
you, but not at all of you,
I thought I might give a very
short introduction about myself.
So I also trained at Leiden
University as an art historian,
and at the moment I'm
head of department
at their Cultural Heritage Agency.
And I'm board member of
various European initiatives
like the JPI, IPERION
and also E-RIHS.
And my specialties are not in
chemistry or [inaudible] but really,
art historian, sort of studies
like the art of collecting,
the art of natural stone,
and all kinds of conservation
and heritage issues.
So, about our agency, like I said
we are a part of the Ministry
of Education of Science and Culture.
And we have some facilities
in Amsterdam
and our main premises in Amersfoort.
But we have laboratories in both,
350 fte's so we are
middle-sized agency.
And we have a lot of
various functions.
So we give grants, we lease
buildings, we do research, and well,
among us are several
university professors
like Klaas Jan van den Berg,
who is present at the moment.
And we also-- and I will want to
conclude at the end of next version
of my presentation which
will be on the internet.
We also maintain a unique
collection of reference materials,
which is especially interesting
of course for the data approach.
We are having today.
We are also partner in
the Netherlands Institute
for Conservation Art and
Science, also known as NICAS,
which is chaired by the Rijksmuseum.
And I would also like to state
and if you were today the Dutch
government recently has adapted a
very specific attention
to open science.
So whereas up until now,
also regard is important.
As from this year on open
science will be paramount
for all research being funded
by the Dutch government.
Just a very quick insight into
Dutch heritage since I'm talking
about the JPI, but also
as a Dutch representative,
so I will have some
pictures of on the left,
[inaudible] outside
laboratory for water current
and the top picture is the
Royal Barge built in 1815.
And on the right hand side is
the Great Synagogue in Amsterdam,
still in use and still
only lit by candles.
And we also have of course world
heritage site in the Netherlands
and the center-- the center
picture is a famous modern movement,
factory in Rotterdam but on
the right and left hand side,
you see world heritage sites,
hope-- which we hope will be listed
and they are at the
moment and they--
I have taken pictures
of both these sites
because they are not
specifically Dutch sites,
but because they are
sites which are--
which will be nominated together
with for instance Belgium
or for instance with Germany.
So we are looking cooperation
not only within research,
but also all kinds
of other initiatives.
Now this is what you came for,
the joint program initiative.
And I want to say something
about it.
That we were established in 2010.
And I had a very short
dark with the lady
from [inaudible] commission
during the break,
we are of course very
glad we were supported
by the European Commission.
But I would also like to stress,
we are not a European institution.
We are an institution
of member states.
So we are-- go funding from
the European Commission,
but we are member state driven
so there are seven member states
within European, who
constitute the board.
And there are eight associated
countries, from which one,
Israel is from outside of Europe.
And we have of course the various
sets of board, the government board,
executive board, scientific
committee, and then advisory board.
And the second part of the
slide you see, so like I said,
we were run by member states.
If we launch calls, we
[inaudible] inform ourselves,
some calls have a top-up
from the European Commission,
so under Horizon 2020 or the
following framework programs,
we get additional funding
from Brussels
and we are essentially
a research program.
So we, of course, do care for
advocacy of cultural heritage
and all the things that
surround research, but mainly,
we are a research program.
We are not the only joint
program initiative alive.
There are 10.
And there are about-- so
for instance, oceans, water,
neurodegenerative diseases,
so that's always a mouthful.
And I have a brochure about what we
are as a set of programs with me.
So again, during the break, I'll
be happy to share it with you.
Well, under-- on the slide you
see the team which is working
on a joint program,
programming initiative.
Photographed during a
meeting in the Hague
and central is our secretary general
for culture education and science.
So it is really-- so being
fostered the top level people
at our ministry.
I mentioned the member state and
associated countries involved
and on the left hand side you
see a small map indicating
which countries are involved
and the faded blue ones are in,
and the darker blue ones
are observing states.
So let's give you the pictures
and so almost all of Europe is in
and of course, we are
striving to get the ones
who are not fully in also onboard.
We have-- When we look
at France [inaudible],
we have a slightly different
approach because we do look
at all kinds of heritage and
not only the tangible heritage,
although with the focus on
conservation and restoration
of monuments or museums, but we
look into all kinds of heritage.
And so this material,
immaterial and digital heritage.
So like I said, the aim of the joint
program initiative is to foster
and to empower research and for this
of course we have--
we made some effort.
And the first one is what do
we want to research in the end.
And it is in our strategic
research agenda,
which is also to be
seen on the internet.
And we have launched several
calls for proposals until now.
And we have also joint
activities amongst partners.
Because it is fine to do funded
research, but there is a lot
of knowledge already
present among the partners.
And why shouldn't we share
that knowledge too and only aim
at extending knowledge
via new research.
So via the joint activities,
we tried to share the
existing knowledge.
Two calls were launched
nevertheless in 2012 and 2014,
and we will launch three
next-- sorry , four new goals--
calls over the next three
years and in the final version
of my PowerPoint, I will show
the entity exact phrasing
of the upcoming goals, which will be
on digital heritage on conservation
and restoration on
heritage and perception
and on changing environments.
Now just a few more words about
strategic research agenda.
So we are not only research drive,
but we are also very much
content driven as a consortium.
Like I said, member
states do take part,
but of course several
institutions like ministries
or funding agencies
constitute the board of the JPI
to have a very direct contact
with all the partners
and all the countries.
The agenda is composed of
four priority areas reflect--
so developing a reflective society,
connecting people with heritage,
creating knowledge and safeguarding
the cultural heritage resource.
The agenda was not put
together by the board itself,
but we consultated [phonetic]
all member states involved
and what they did was established
a national consultation panel.
And this proved to be very
interesting opportunity
within countries to really
set culture heritage research
on the agenda as something which
is a joint effort within a country
Because like you saw
in the Netherlands,
cultural heritage was
established in say about 1870
as a specific responsibility
of the government.
But then while there were
some persons and they dealt
with archeology and
they dealt with archives
and so the whole world heritage
was present within some people.
But in 150 years, you have--
the whole field was scattered
and this national consultation
panel gave us the opportunity
to bring all those people together
in-- physically in one room.
And of course, not all of them
but the major representatives
for the first time in 150 years.
And this really gave [inaudible]
Netherlands to say, well,
cultural heritage is
not a scattered field.
We are in contact.
We are really working
together on agenda.
And I think this might
be interesting also.
Well for instance, in the USA
looking from Europe or looking
from myself, I always look
at the USA as one country,
but of course like was stated,
in effect is 50 states, and well,
so perhaps your approach
of bringing people together
and you might already do.
So pardon me if I'm not--
if I am being rude or having
two large [inaudible].
But it really helps to bring
people together so well we have
to make one agenda and we
bring all people together
and it was really stimulating.
Now the upcoming activities
like I said were four new
calls for the next years.
We also have to revise our strategic
research agenda because it's
about five years old now
and although we included a foresight
planning chapter, you see there--
whereas conservation and restoration
are still very important issues,
you also see the ethical side
of how you look at heritage,
and how you look at heritage
professionals is getting more
and more impact over the last years.
And also because of
course in Europe,
we have had an economic
crisis and we've seem
to pull ourselves together.
But within Europe, you also have--
well, I'm not so strange
with 500 million inhabitants
but you have very [inaudible]
currents at the moment,
which will need us to reconsider
not only why we do research but also
in what frame do we do research
and who do we actually
do the research for.
So who are for instance
the end-users.
And we are also at the JPI looking
at enlarging the partnership
possibly also outside Europe
and we have set up
a special taskforce
which Luca knows very
well, Luca Pezzati to for--
to strengthen the bones between the
joint program branding initiative
on one side and the
E-RIHS on the other side.
And anybody who is doing which
work of art you are looking at,
at the moment at the right
end, it's called [inaudible].
So how does JPI fit into
the landscape of data
and research infrastructures.
And for those longing for the next
speaker, this will be my last slide.
And so on the left hand side,
of course you see the
joint program initiative.
On the right hand side,
you see the E-RIHS.
It is kind of a jigsaw.
So of course you'll meet each other
on the content, quality systems
for instance, but basically
the joint program initiative is
about programming, about financing
and has European outreach,
and it includes all kinds
of cultural heritage.
Whereas at the moment, E-RIHS, which
is just getting started, we must--
so we will have our
kickoff meeting next year,
will be more of a hands-on program.
It will focus on infrastructure,
so it is--
so it complements the joint
program initiative on that side
because we are mainly
ministries and funders,
whereas that E-RIHS
will be, of course,
more on the institutional side.
And of course, E-RIHS
aims at a global outreach.
At the moment, the European
research infrastructure is European,
but the global outreach
was already mentioned
and the focus will be mainly on
the material cultural heritage.
So I think we complement each other.
We have already found each other
and the next years will be--
well, we will be working
of really joining forces.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Monique Bossi: Thank you Jan.
We move now to the last, not
presentation but intervention.
As I said earlier on, unfortunately,
Elizabeth Tran couldn't
be here today.
So we thank Jong-on Hahm to
take over our intervention.
Jong-on Hahm is from the
George Washington University.
As a background, she has
also PhD in neurosciences.
So, we have now another
type of background.
We had chemistry, we had
material science, art historian
and now we have neuroscience.
So a very interesting panel.
Thank you for this.
And in George Washington University,
she is focusing on global investment
in science, technology
and engineering and math,
sort of famous STEM that were
mentioned during the opening speech.
And today, she will present
briefly the European platform,
the transatlantic platform for
social science and humanities.
So another European
initiative that try to group
and to pull together different
countries and initiative.
Thank you.
>> Jong-on Hahm: Thank you.
So first, I'll just like-- what is
an interloping neuroscientist doing
at a cultural heritage
science meeting?
I just wanted to say,
Elizabeth couldn't be here
because she became ill.
Elizabeth Tran and I were
both program directors
at the National Science Foundation.
So when I was at the
National Science Foundation,
I was in the international
office and part
of my portfolio was the
country desk for Italy
and also the European Union.
It is how the state department joint
committee meeting in organizing
that was the first cultural
heritage working group
at the GCM, was the US-Italy one.
So, I'm not going to step in for
Elizabeth, but to give a little--
the transatlantic partnership
challenge most likely came,
giving you a perspective
from a funder's perspective.
We had a great perspective
from Odile.
She's a researcher, you
know, people in the--
doing the work, but trying to fund
the work as Riccardo said earlier,
budgets always seem to
be shrinking constantly.
There are always cuts.
We always have to deal
with do more with less.
And even when they don't shrink,
because of costs going
up, you can't do as much.
We used to joke at NSF, the
NSF's budget was supposed
to have been doubled at least three
times in the past two decades,
according to authorization
legislation.
It hasn't.
It's been flat.
So, our joke was, flat
is the new doubling
because at least there's not a cut.
So, as a funder, you want to
make sure that you're leveraging
in getting the most
bang for the buck
because this is all public dollars.
All return on investment
is great and so--
and there's a lot of work as you
know, having been probably asked
to review, you know,
proposals or papers.
So if we could some of the--
streamline some of the same things
that people are doing because
people are working together,
science is global, you're
publishing in the same journals, so,
these efforts and I think there
will be more of them, to have not--
maybe not quite joint
programming initiative,
but parallel working together
with collaborative connection.
So that the science moves forward
without every single scientist
and researcher being forced
to understand the same minutia
of every single funding agency.
And so, let me get-- so
transatlantic partnership,
the one I know about most is digging
into data because it was a project
that was launched I believe at
NSF in the social, behavioral,
and economic sciences directorate.
This is essentially to allow
US researchers to collaborate
with their, at the time,
it was European partners,
without so much the
funding barriers.
And what TAP has done, if you look
into the partnership, there are--
the agency partners are
from all over Europe.
Let me see.
Let me pull this up on
my little-- just working.
So of course you see
Academy of Finland,
Arts and Humanities Research Council
of UK, CONACYT of Chile and CONACYT
of Mexico, DFG Germany, ESRC,
Portugal, CNR France, the French CNR
and of course, the
European Commission
to make it hopefully easier
for researchers, for--
to not have everyone doing the
same thing at the same time.
So kind of a perpetual motion
where everybody is running their
own little wheel and to put the--
to leverage the capacity because
if any research field could--
deserves to leverage the
capacity that they have,
since the capacity is so scattered
and is so uneven across the world,
it should be the cultural
heritage sciences.
So I'm going to stop and I think
Elizabeth said she would try
to come tomorrow, perhaps
you could ask her questions
and then we would have more time for
questions for the other panelists.
Thank you.
>> Monique Bossi: Thank
you, Jong-on.
[ Applause ]
OK. I think we can open the
floor also with Luca and Odile.
>> Antonio Sgamellotti:
Luca was mentioning the G7.
Next year, we are going to have
the political summit in May
in [inaudible], but before there
will be the G7 for science,
the 23 and 24 that the [inaudible].
Three statements will be discussed
and approved by the G7 and then
to the political artist of the G7.
The first one is cultural heritage,
a building resilience to disasters.
This is an important topic and
guest countries will decide
that will be the first statement
to present to the G7 for science.
The other two are very important,
aging society, a new economic roles.
We have already prepared.
I am responsible with my colleague
of the University of Geneva,
Giovanni to prepare the statements.
The statement is all ready,
but it has to be discussed
by the G7 academies before
deliver it to the public.
It will follow the document that
we already approved in Rome .
The 11 to 13 of October, there was
a conference in Rome in occasion
of the 50 anniversary of the
Florence Club and the title
of the conference was Florence
1966-2016 Resilience of City of Arts
to Natural Disaster,
the Role of Academies.
And at the end of the meeting,
we approved the charter of Rome
on the resilience of art
city to natural disasters.
It was approved by all the
Academy of Science of the world,
more than 116 academy approved it
and is already available in the web.
If you type IAP.
This is the acronym of the network
of all the Academy of Science,
IAP and then charter of
Rome, you will get the PDF
of the document of
the charter of Rome.
Thank you.
>> Monique Bossi: Thank you,
Professor Sgamelloti
for this addition.
>> Fenella France: I will
repeat the question which was
for the European representatives to
talk about their approach as opposed
to the American approach and
various [inaudible] as well.
>> Luca Pezzati: My opinion
is there is a top-down process
and it is more the JPI consortium
and bottom-up scientific process.
And this is more the
IPERION E-RIHS so we'll
from the top-down, you know.
>> Jan van't Hof: Well,
I won't exactly say the
JPI is only a top-down,
but it is member state-driven.
So it is different than
an institution-driven
and what helped us was
making an agenda together.
So then, you'd have to-- you
get to talk about the content
and then you find you have
the same interest, you are--
you have the same fascination.
So that really helps within the
countries but also, within Europe.
When you want to put together
financial resources, it's--
it also helps because then
you really have the exposure
in your own country, say, that
country is giving so much money,
they're giving their money, so then
you can-- your own country say,
well, look at other member states
are doing, we shouldn't left behind.
So that also helps
in a vice versa way.
So you want to be part of it but you
are-- you also want to-- if you--
if you are in, you
should really join too.
On the other hand, really pulling
financial resources is always
difficult because you have various
ways of really sharing the money.
And at the moment that they still
an issue on money being pulled,
but it also mainly comes back
into national researchers grounds.
>> What's their agenda?
>> Jan van't Hof: Agenda is a
very good starting point both
on the European level
and at national level.
>> Luca Pezzati: About what--
Before answering about want
Antonio was saying that the day
after tomorrow, we'll
be in Brussels.
The event organized by the
commission cultural heritage,
disaster resilience in climate
change, the contribution
of European research and innovation.
And in the afternoon, Hilde
De Clercq will speak--
will present the E-RIHS
infrastructure
of these events in Brussels.
About what we were saying, I am
a firm sustainer of the concept
that with money, everything
is easier.
So if you found money for research,
you can coordinate research,
you can defragment research,
you can involve researchers
and research organization.
This firm belief is also
supported by my career.
I started putting together
money from grants in 1998.
I was a very young scientist.
And it was-- That's the date of my
first external financed project,
and then continue and established
the research group in the Institute
of Optics just by finding
money for having them work.
So simply these and
it is very fortunate
that we have Brussels
Horizon project and all
of the framework project because
it is something that, in a sense,
is forcing European
researchers to cooperate.
And the difference is obvious.
Here, the United States
is a much older federation
of states than the European one.
So in Europe, there has been, in
these 20 years, the necessity,
political necessity of
putting on the table tools
for having real collaboration
between European researchers
that also have the problem of not
speaking the same language even
if there's not exactly one
English throughout the US.
It was my understanding.
But we have a guardian,
we are Finnish,
we have a bit of difficulties with
several truly different languages,
and it is why CLARIN is one of the
research infrastructures in Europe.
So, about these, the real person
to whom addressed this question,
how do you have the people
cooperating is not me.
Because I entered in a very
well-established environment
of cooperation.
The real person to ask this
question is Bruno Brunetti,
who started the process and
the Framework Programme 5
and he built the European
family of cultural heritage.
When I stepped into the
process, this was five years ago,
and everything was well advanced.
So my job has been simply to
sell these and to find new ways
of exploiting this very nice
situation of cooperation
that I found already
existing in Europe.
>> Fenella France: OK.
>> Well, I don't know
to be provocative.
But just as-- and we heard that we--
we all know that we are in a moment
where we have a lot of budgeting
constraints, and the key point
for cultural aid, it used to make
the decision maker aware of the fact
that cultural heritage is something
that deserves the attention
from the financing committee.
If this is the case,
I see any of the--
I'm a little bit confused
of this really
between this joint programming
initiatives and E-RIHS
because they both rely
on at member state level,
in the sense that the
future Italian not--
and the joint programming
initiative,
the Italian joint programming
initiative, they both have
to finance their activities,
is that true?
What does it mean?
That it will arrive at a point
where a decision has been made,
has to be taken on whether to
finance what one or-- and the other.
Even though there are
difference between them,
the joint programming initiative
as Jan was saying is dealing
with general heritage, the
E-RIHS just being with material--
with the materiality of heritage.
But regardless the fact
of what is dealing what,
as a matter of fact [inaudible]
that we will arrive at a point
that the member states has to,
you know, to put money on that
and beyond, how do you see this
probably a small battle within--
well, it-- probably, it
will not be a battle.
But there is also a decision
maker, a decision-making process
that I don't understand how
will be-- how will be tackled.
>> Fenella France:
And just for the--
>> Is it clear what I'm asking?
>> Fenella France: So
for the filming here,
to shrink it a little bit,
how big can the bottle be
and how do you engage with the
management and the member states
to make a decision about what
should be funded and I am assuming,
how do we prioritize that funding?
>> Yeah.
>> Jan van't Hof: Well,
just to start the answer
and Luca will follow I suppose.
Some, say 10 years ago, the field
of cultural heritage was much
more [inaudible] at the moment
and also had not a focal point.
And what we see now and that is,
that for instance that European year
of cultural heritage in 2018 will
really emphasize the importance
of cultural heritage in Europe.
So what we are seeing now
is that generally speaking,
the political interest in cultural
heritage in Europe is really growing
and will, we hope, dominate in
European cultural heritage 2018.
So we are at the moment
not in a bad time
to have several initiatives
on cultural heritage.
It is our task, I firmly
believe that we will--
we explained to the decision makers,
we are not in a battle ourselves
but we are willing trying to
cooperate and to share our resources
and what's the interest of the
decision makers is that in the end,
if we have a firm collaboration, we
can at least say to decision makers
if you want to call something--
sorry, if you want to call someone
about cultural heritage issues,
there is this good working--
well, so what I say, bipolar, well,
not institution, but
bipolar approach.
>> Luca Pezzati: But the answer
is almost complete in the sense
that that's not competition at all.
It's just a synergy between the
joint programming initiative
and the infrastructure because we
are doing totally different jobs.
So, the joint programming
initiatives are political container
developing a strategy
research agenda
and they already developed it,
involving the cultural heritage
research throughout Europe,
and then the concern is to form a
research initiative across Europe
with what is available
at European level.
Why? The infrastructure
produces services,
so it's funded for another activity.
It's servicing research.
There's been a nice debate in Venice
last week, how much we need to spend
in research infrastructure in
order for research to be efficient?
Currently in Europe, the
percentage is around 15 to 20%
of resources going directly to
research infrastructure and the bulk
of it going to finance research.
These are the figures.
What is more difficult for
us is not the competition
with the joint research initiative
that in the beginning may be
for some problems understanding
things was there,
in ministries across Europe, but
now the situation is very clear.
We are an [inaudible] project
and the joint programming
initiative is a JPI.
So it's very clear the rules even in
the face of politicians not having
to do daily with cultural
heritage or heritage science.
The real trouble is totally
different and I had confirmation
of it in the most recent
meeting that I had
in Vienna towards an
interministerial meeting in Austria
because also in Austria, they
have the ministry of culture
so there was representative
of ministry of culture,
ministry of education and ministry
of research and the delegates
of the ministry of research
had difficulty understanding
which is the role of E-RIHS aspect
project comparison with DALIAH ERIC,
CLARIN ERIC so what's already
there into the ESFRI roadmap.
That is the real problem for the
moment, that I don't understand
because they are outside our field
and I cannot say they are stupid.
They simply don't understand
which are the different roles
of research infrastructures in
Europe and that is understandable
and that is where the risk is
because we are the last in the line
of ESFRI project that now we
made money from member states.
So we need to explain
that and not the duality
with the joint programming
initiative.
That it's already a synergy.
We already have a table and we
have a joint interface group
where we discussed of the role
of research infrastructures.
>> Jan van't Hof: And we also
have some personal unions, so.
>> Luca Pezzati: Yup.
>> I don't think that is so
clear because in [inaudible]
at least my impression is that they
so is improved cultural
heritage initiatives.
This is [inaudible] because
the institution in trying
to gather them, if not we could
do with money to [inaudible]
so we must be stressed that we have
two completely different vendors,
runs [inaudible] cultural
heritage, the other is through focus
on research, [inaudible].
>> Luca Pezzati: No, that's
not yet done here because--
[ Inaudible Remark ]
So initially, there's find
the support for E-RIHS is
within the national research plan
for research infrastructures.
So it completely separate from the
support of Italy to the initiatives
of the joint programming initiative.
We need to know what will happen
with the Framework
Programme 9 approaching
because there are several problems,
because the first problem is
that we don't know the UK position
so if the UK is not paying for FP9,
the budget will be
totally different.
It will not have UK
participant, applicants
and that may be a good
point considering
that they are winning everything.
>> Monique Bossi: But
this is already--
>> Luca Pezzati: But the
world would be different.
The attitude of [inaudible]
is different
from the attitude of the previous--
>> Monique Bossi: Commissioner.
>> Luca Pezzati: -- commissioner.
So we don't even know the focus
on research infrastructure,
how will be, our structure
will be, so there is--
>> Monique Bossi: Just at the
beginning of the discussion.
>> Luca Pezzati: But maybe Monique
can say something on this point.
>> Monique Bossi: On FP9, no.
It's a little bit premature.
>> Luca Pezzati: I'll
give you Monique.
>> Monique Bossi: No, no.
Whatever I would say it would
be really, I mean, premature.
But what I can say is that I
think we have reached the end
of this morning session.
It's already-- yes, 12, so I invite
you for an hour break so we try
to convene back at 10
past 2, 10 past 1, sorry.
And Fenella, anything
you want to talk.
>> Fenella France: So,
please if you can all join me
in thanking the panel
for the presentations.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.